these days it can be pretty hard for
esports enthusiasts to not only settle
on a mouse
but
actually stick with one from the swanky
super lights to the space alloy swiss
cheeses to the killer shapes side
buttons and scroll wheels to the fact
that you get pair recorded cables and
aftermarket grade skates straight out of
the box
the mouse market has pretty much gone
nuclear this right here is a prototype
of the atom palm hydrogen the best
gaming mouse on the market
theoretically the glorious pc gaming
race model o one of the lightest most
anticipated gaming mouse of 2019 an
extra fight deserve some credit for this
one the m4 rgb what an amazing entry
into this very exciting yet competitive
my segment here's the thing though like
a lot of edgy aging counter-strike
elitists i have zero interest in
switching to any of these weightless
wireless rgbfi zoomer doohickeys
like the good lord intended i use one
mouse and one mouse only
a zowie
and i [ __ ] hate it
well that's not true
i hate things about it i hate that it is
a clunky tethered brick with a two-ton
cable mushy scroll wheel and scratchy
skates what i and countless cultists
across the whole of esports love
is the shape despite being slow to adapt
zowie's sublime and foundational designs
have allowed them to remain as goated as
the day they began to revolutionize the
gaming mouse industry nearly 15 years
ago
zowies are and forever will be estier or
will they are other brands simply
catching up to zowie or are they eating
zowie's lunch
and
if the latter
what is howie gonna do about it
[Applause]
okay so before we dive into the nitty
gritty of it all i gotta do the youtube
thing and ask that you like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications your boy is on the verge
of buying his a third za11 and is sorely
in need of that sweet sweet ad revenue
so please kids
start
clicking now for those who don't know
and if you aren't an fps player there's
a good chance you don't
zowie by ben q is a fabled peripheral
manufacturer whose esports centric
innovations have long been regarded as
the gold if not platinum standard in
competitive gaming the reason for this
of course is largely due to the thing
for which zowie was first known
their mice nowadays zowie offers a
variety of shapes in a variety of sizes
but way back in the late 2000s when the
then non-benq owned startup was first
founded they entered the market with
only one optical offering a clicker
they'd worked tirelessly to
conceptualize and create and what an
offering it was
in fact you may have heard of it since
by most accounts it is reckoned to be
the mona freaking lisa of gaming mice
the ec
designed in collaboration with
counter-strike legend heaton the larger
zowie ec1 and smaller ec2 were sleek
elongated ergonomic masterpieces within
no time the ec had cemented itself as a
go-to clicker for counter-strikers in
particular as i'm sure you all know cs
is was a slow sweaty slugfest in which
low sensitivity was ubiquitous so it
made sense to use a sort of smooth
simplistic brick that could be enveloped
by the hand and swung by the arm zowie
did go on to release some other shapes
of course like the starcraft driven miko
and ambidextrous spawn designed am but
virtually all of them failed to catch on
and eventually faded into obscurity for
it was the ec that really took hold of
fps esports i have the zoe ec2 blue
which will be coming out really really
soon using ec2 black with zoe speedy
skates
as uh as mouse we use the ec2 blue i use
the white ec1
[Music]
[Applause]
default mouse gates so why is that
well for starters because it was
designed explicitly with esports in mind
both dpi and eventually polling rates
could be adjusted from the bottom of the
mouse via physical buttons meaning that
you didn't have to install drivers or
customization software on some random
lan tournament pc if you wanted to go
compete somewhere and change your
sensitivity it also came in different
sizes which
matters
like a lot
i cannot tell you how many mice i have
abandoned over the years either for
being too big or too small
irrespective of the fact that i actually
really liked the shape
and speaking of shape
that is where the ec
truly
just
shines here to help us understand why
the ec is so unremittingly esteer is my
day one ride or die ergo homie garrick
forman a phd candidate at brock
university who specializes in esports
related biomechanics well looking at the
ec it absolutely does have a classic
design to it and there's a reason that
every other manufacturer is picking up
this design because there's nothing
forcing into any kind of awkward posture
it really lets you adapt to what's
comfortable for you so the more
adjustable something is the better it is
ergonomically just like sitting in a
chair adjusting and moving is good the
ability to adjust on a mouse and not
just stick in the same posture for eight
hours 12 hours a day i think it's really
beneficial and
the fact that the ec is
is such a
i don't know if i would say it's like a
blank canvas almost
um and it's simplicity so it allows you
to really adjust for what's comfortable
for you and it allows you to adjust and
change as you go if something is
starting to bother you a little bit you
don't have to force your hand at that
same posture now i want to be clear the
ec series isn't actually for everyone
like don't get me wrong
it is a clear contender for the most
important and influential gaming mouse
ever made and i am gassing it up for
good reason
but it does have its drawbacks
i for one
can't stand the thing over and above the
fact that you need to be right-handed to
use one and that unless your twists it
sort of forces the user into a palm grip
the hump is situated towards the center
which i hate and the back is flatter
than an eighth grade orchestra this
makes it harder to not only grab the
mouse with the back center of the palm
but sort of steer it since there's
nothing for her to latch onto
zowie were aware of this of course and
after being acquired by benq in late
2015 began designing a whole new array
of alternatives from the low profile fk
to the short snubby s to the back heavy
z-a which i use
zowie spent the next five plus years
innovating a variety of equally safe
symmetrical designs that taken
collectively could genuinely be said to
satisfy an fps competitor's every whim
and cry they do seem like very minuscule
differences but when you're thinking
about the
the duration
of use of the
the fine motor skills that you're using
when you're using a mouse and how long
you're using it for those little tiny
changes become huge changes it's so
important because in ergonomics
we design things for
individuals who fall between the 5th and
95th percentile of measures before long
zowie had pretty much solidified
themselves as the mouse to beat in
competitive fps their popularity was
most pronounced in cs go of course with
according to zowie's 2021 census about
60
of pros using either version of the ec
now that's not to say that the
ambidextrous models weren't popular they
were in fact they became the go-to for
some pretty big names
here's the thing though as esports
became increasingly mainstream and mouse
and keyboard fps started undergoing a
renaissance of sorts
so too did the science and structures
around
well
aiming before long you had all these
competitors reviewers and customers
feasting their eyes on not only which
peripherals were available and what made
them good or bad but how they could be
improved and at some point zowie started
to get i wouldn't say outmoded because
their mice were still very relevant
but they were sure [ __ ] being outpaced
with manufacturers old and new racing to
make their products as light bright and
optimized as possible zowie fans started
to get frustrated that this fabled mouse
maker looked to be resting on its
laurels watching as other companies took
their shapes and improved upon them in
ways that zowie themselves ostensibly
couldn't be bothered to peripheral
companies do this thing where like when
they have something they don't really
update it or like take good care of it
thank you
like that's maybe that's not fair but
like i think zowie's been a bit
complacent in recent years compared to
where they used to be because minus a
few notable exceptions
the vast majority of mouse shapes that
have made waves over the past couple of
years
have been
heavily inspired by zowie
and with good reason zowie's shapes are
second to none and if they're not going
to be the ones to bring their legendary
blueprints into the modern age then [ __ ]
somebody should and to be clear there's
nothing wrong with that
capitalism may not be very based but it
does give way to better products by way
of competition innovation and yes
imitation the question of course
is
well there are several the first is how
outdated are zowie's mice really i would
say that up until about six months ago
the answer was
very they were heavy had awful scroll
wheels and the rubber cables still drive
me up the wall now the reason that zowie
never went wireless was sort of
understandable since they'd ceased to be
plug and play but no paracord
really
come on oh and for those who don't know
what a paracord is it's just a fabric
coating around your cable instead of a
rubber one makes it more malleable
lighter easier to move and is all around
life-changing in terms of the actual
sensor
i have no idea
which is perfect because as i'm sure
many of you know colton is something of
a controller wielding console scrub and
so there was no real like organic way to
integrate his voice into this episode
until i needed a turbo dork to talk
about optical stuff
so yeah
uh floor's yours slugger and now the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about man this dimitri guy is really
starting to get full of himself one of
these days i just gotta host my own
episode of cracked and stick him in his
own little segment call it the guy who
most definitely doesn't know what he's
talking about
let me know in the comments i actually
talked about mouse sensors back in our
video about the logitech g pro so if you
haven't watched that finish this video
because youtube algorithm and then click
over there and check that out too to
make a long and technical story short
the optical sensor in your mouse is
essentially a very small very fast
camera that takes pictures of the
surface it's moving across to determine
speed and direction then translates that
into cursor movement on your screen
going from trackball to optical sensors
was obviously a giant leap forward but
where have my sensors gone from there
and do they even matter anymore well
when dimitri said the mouse market had
gone nuclear
he wasn't kidding let's take a look at
the sensor used in some of the most
recent zowie mice for reference the
pixar 3360. this tiny camera is able to
capture 12 000 frames per second motion
at 250 inches per second and
acceleration up to 50 g's that's 50
times earth's standard gravitational
force for the uninitiated or somewhere
in the neighborhood of 490 meters per
second per second
like
what needless to say we're pretty far
outside the realm of human limits at
this point and it isn't just zowie
either you'll find similarly over the
top numbers in basically any sensor used
by every major mouse manufacturer with
mice now hitting the market touting
polling rates of 8 000 hertz i think
it's safe to say we're well into the
zone of diminishing returns the jump
from 125 hertz to a thousand hertz is a
seven millisecond difference whereas
going from a thousand to eight 000 hertz
even though we're going eight times
faster again
it's just a 0.75 millisecond difference
is it possible to feel such a small
change sure the companies that make
these mouse sensors are likely to keep
upping the ante for marketing's sake but
most people agree that we're already
past the point where you would actually
be able to tell the difference between
one mouse sensor and another every major
peripheral company is going to have a
quote-unquote flawless implementation of
their sensor meaning there are no
distortions in the signal between the
sensor the microcontroller and your pc
it's always worth double checking before
you buy a mouse but you're pretty safe
with major brands these days so does the
most sensor matter well for those of us
normal human beings who don't use a
360hz monitor and don't adjust our
crosshair on a per pixel basis
no i'm not suggesting you don't do your
research and know what you're getting
when you buy a mouse but at the end of
the day the much more important part of
that decision is the shape weight and
feature set of the mouse don't let
flashy marketing numbers trick you into
buying a mouse that isn't right for your
hand and that was the guy who actually
knows what he's talking about so yeah
zowies are obviously serviceable in the
modern era but
they're not ideal the question is like
how far from not ideal even i a lifelong
zowie devotee after having been
fortunate enough to receive an outset
from vacci a few months back which is
basically just a lighter leaner ec with
better
well everything found that i was hitting
shots that would have felt heavier or
just more exerting with a zowie
and the reason for this is pretty simple
lighter mice are within a reasonable
threshold
just better don't believe me ask the
actual scientist it honestly it's kind
of like
i don't know if you ever watched like
dragon ball z very much one of us
definitely has there's a point where
goku has weighted clothes on and he
takes them off and he moves so much
faster i think it's a little bit like
that where if you use a super heavy
mouse you go to a light wind you're
going to go a lot faster but it's a lot
harder to adjust to if you have a heavy
mouse you you don't have a ton of
control on your wrist you're going to
have to use a lot of muscle to move your
wrist isolated so a lot of people move
to a shoulder aiming um but taking the
weight out allows you to do a bit of
both which gives you a lot more fine
control of where you're aiming now to be
fair to be fair
have made some recent adaptations that
are
significant in fact about midway through
2020 they unveiled an entirely new shape
and i entirely knew i mean they made a
handful of imperceptible changes to the
ec and dubbed it the ec3 the overall
length of the ec3 is shorter than the
ec2
and more space has been created in the
base of the palm area
allowing slightly more flexibility in
movement
this freedom of movement on the ec3 can
be especially noticed when moving the
mouse in an upward or downward motion or
a flick
what's more they announced that they'd
be releasing a whole new updated c line
of mice
which added drum roll please
paracords and a 24 step scroll wheel to
their existing 80 models yay
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine when you're not
really fine
memes aside as sad as it may sound this
is actually a huge improvement for us
zowie stands i don't need the mouse to
be wireless i just need it to be pay
recorded have a functional scroll wheel
and be light enough that it stops being
obliterated by the competition
as for what the next update looks like
who's to say wireless has been rumored
for ever but who knows the other
question obviously
is why are zowie so slow to adapt like
why improve your products at a
purposefully glacial pace
the short answer is because for a long
time they didn't really feel the need or
the pressure to ramp things up
for a long time people stuck with zowie
no matter what even now in 2022 having
tried a myriad of alternatives i cannot
bring myself to switch off the za11
there's simply no other shape like it
nothing that's long and wide enough to
support my 20 by 10 centimeter sized
hands and has it so that the hump sits
towards the back i've tried glorious
extra five razor logitech steel series
vaccine final mouse you name it none of
them make a single mouse that scratches
that edge for me i've waited years for a
mouse that could suitably replace my
za11
and try as i might i cannot for the life
of me to find one and it's precisely
because of this as well as how
accustomed to zoe's products competitors
have become that the brand's slow and
steady design philosophy has carried it
this far and don't get me wrong there is
value in taking your time with these
types of things from an ergonomic
standpoint i think it's a it's not a bad
thing to go slower because again you get
to see the physical effects does
changing this one little thing doesn't
make people enjoy the mouse more i think
there's probably a happy middle ground
between 14 years and
every year or something like that people
like me now are getting into the
industry and we're realizing you know
what gaming is not going anywhere
esports is not going anywhere this is
something we need to start researching
if they had a team doing some research
they could actually be getting some
studies done bring it into a lab get
people to use it look at comfort look at
performance things like that and and
having those big
time periods between
different iterations of the mouth allows
you to do that which a lot of companies
don't do but with the rest of the
industry not only catching up but kind
of soaring ahead it does seem as if
zowie's finally feeling the heat will
zowie ever actually go wireless make a
swiss cheese mouse or implement some
other sort of radical earth-shattering
change
i hope so but until that day comes if it
ever comes
i'm just thankful that they are
listening to their community of
supporters somewhat
i've stuck with them this far i can't
stop now and listen chances are
it'll be worth the wait
because if history is any indication the
day that zowie's next big innovation
does come
it'll change
everything
it's gonna slap really hard colton
trying to get more tick-tock humor into
our videos i don't know if you're a man
on tick-tock these days but no i'm not
oh you should be bro i i was i was a
non-believer until dan rosen
convinced my my girlfriend got me a tech
talk like more recently but dan rosen
told me like you know you know the
golden age of vine of course you do yeah
of course you do cause you're a man of
culture these zoomers on tick-tock are
doing that again they're actually doing
that again like their humor is so dank
it's so it's so s here that like
it's a whole new age bro